hello everyone and sorry about so many
videos in one day but this is the first
official video world official random
championship so I thought it'd be nice
to cover most of the games and the games
are very interesting so I hope you don't
mind that now this is game 3 of the
rapids
Fabiana Caruana versus magnus carlsen
ofcourse and wins one more game then
Fabi is out of the semifinals so Fabi
should really try very hard to win this
one well then not that he doesn't try to
win every game but this one especially
so with the white pieces Fabi opened
with e4 and it's not going to be so easy
to develop your bishops this game as
they are not on same squares as in the
previous one so after round 1 and 2 now
the position changes we we get a new
setup so with E 5 by Magnus V 3 now you
want to open up your dark square Bishop
and b6 Magnus does the same
we have f3 strengthening in the center
and now Knight to g6 we have Knight the
g3 and f6 so far a symmetrical a
symmetrical system d4 by fabien Alberta
be for breaking the symmetry attacking
the rook on e1 so rook the e3 are
already a very nice rook lift and now d5
by Magnus with Bishop to b5 again a
developing with an attack on the rock on
e8 c6 blocking the bishop and Bishop to
a6 now with ich a person d4 by Magnus
Bishop captures on d4 now and Knight to
d6 are continuing development with
Knight to d3 attacking the bishop on
before and now Magnus has to decide what
to do here Magnus plays Bishop to a3
which put his puts his Bishop and in a
really weird position because Fabi
pushes b4 and now how are you getting
your bishop out of the room b3 fall by
rook characters on e3 seems like a very
reasonable idea
so Magnus first goes D captures and on
e4
we have Knight captures on e4 and now
Knight to f5 goes after the rook and the
bishop here but it doesn't work out all
that nicely
rook the e2 by Fabi and now the problem
with capturing here for example nice
captors Queen captures with check even
if you block with the Queen
Fabi just goes Queen c3 and
are losing the piece here so now you
have to be very careful here it's a
really weird position for a bishop to be
and so Magnus went Queen to d5 but this
runs into something even worse so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best move for Fabiano in this
position yeah well I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who found
that congratulations on being such an
excellent tactician and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's a
bishop captures an f6 with check
Magnus missed this one and but the Adem
again there weren't all that many good
moves here problem is if you captured an
Knight captures an f6 comes with an
attack on the Queen and a double attack
on the rook here so what you would see
here with the best play from black is
Queen captures on a - getting the Queen
out of the way but now route capture
sunny it with check King to c7 are
getting the the King away from check and
the now King to d2 just getting the King
to safety the Queen out also guards the
rook Queen back to f7 a double attack on
the rook and attacking the knight and
now just rook captures an b8 King
captures and the knight back to e4 and
you you enjoy being being of the
exchange in in a much better position so
of course Fabia would be completely
winning here after Bishop captures an f6
Magnus goes kinked the c7 he says okay I
missed that and now just look the b3 a
nice combo from Fabi saying I'm gonna
grab this piece now so there's no
there's no good square for the pieces so
Bishop captures done before we have
broke out for some before and now G
captures on f6 Magnus now accepts the
piece but it's it's no better now Knight
captures on f6 again a double attack
here we have Queen back to f7 and now
Knight captures on e8 with check rook
captures on e8 and rook captures on e8
with Queen CAD for sunny 8 and now rook
to e4 and now after all is said and done
Bobby Bobby is enjoying his him being up
the exchange and also he's in a much
better position so king the Queen the h8
by Magnus hoping to get some Quinta a1
action for example if the knight moves
you could get me between a1 check
picking up fabi's Queen on g1
but Fabi of course not interested
between 2 e 1 we have Quinta a 1 check
by Magnus and now tonight the c1 c5
magnets now opens up his light square
bishop but rook to e8 we have Quinta d4
with check but now tonight back to d3
and here we have Bishop to d5 a nice
centralizing move by Magnus
but he's still down material so five
minutes for Fabi two minutes for Magnus
in this position we look the c8 with
check across and see now has to go for a
nice walk with King to d6 and now Queen
to e8 so here a lot of ideas become
possible you have to be very careful
what you do across and trice Queen g1
check came to D to end the now Knight
if the e7 trying to set up sort of a
double Knight defense here but as we
always say you know two knights
defending each other almost never works
out so rub the DA to check my Fabi King
to e6 and now rook captures on d5 point
is of course the knight cannot capture
and if rook captures then you also pick
up the other night as well so Queen
captures on g2 with check King to c3 and
now Queen captures on f3
we have Bishop the c8 with check King
has to go further away for walk King to
f6 and now across on is down to 50
seconds worse Bobby has some two and a
half minutes so rook the v6 with check
King to g5 and now Queen to d8 just just
nicely pinning this night across and
escapes with the King even further King
h5 and now Bobby finds h3 so threatening
back of the g4 just winning the Queen
cross and has to continue either running
with the king or queen tip 7 getting the
Queen out of there we have Bishop to g4
with check King to h6 and now rook the
e6 a slow slow move but it really sets
the black you don't really have a move
here the Queen has to keep an eye on the
knight here otherwise you're just gonna
win even more material so what can you
do here we have Queen to g7 checking the
White King Knight to e5 blocking check
you cannot capture because of the pin
here and now King back to
g5 we have Queen to d2 by Fabi with
check came to h4 and now Quinta f2 with
check King to g5 and now here Bobby has
mate in two but he's also done done on
the clock
he's below one minute mark but feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this mate in two while I give you a
couple of seconds you know just a
sharpen your tactics a bit so for those
of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
mating - and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's actually h4 with
check you don't you don't have a good
move if you go King to h6 then Queen to
d2 is mate and if you capture the pawn
if Knight captures on h4 then again the
Queen to d2 is made then I guards the
bishop the rook controls all of these
scores the bishop covers D scores and
Queen covers f4 + delivers check so you
don't have anywhere to go
a Fabi did not go for h4 he first played
Queen back the e3 checked cross and
repeated and now kink the b3 for some
reason he decided that it was important
well with the king and c3 there are
ideas like night at the d5 check picking
up the Queen which doesn't work if you
find mating - but since you know you
don't want to waste all that much time
calculating you just like him to be
three and you're gonna win then so
Carlsen when tonight that be
Knight to d5 but now it's night of 3
check King to g3 and Queen to g1 check
and it was in this position that Magnus
Carlsen resigned the game and Fabi is
back in the in the match he resigned
because of whatever he does it's may
just meet on the next move and there's
nothing he can play he has to go kink
therefore and the next move it's Queen
to h2 and this will now be made since
the king has nowhere to go so that's
that's it for Game three of the rapids I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank georgiana bronzy Nadeau Mohamed
matheus mast monocle Nielsen and
Alexander Kovalenko for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
probably would game for all the rapid
unless it will really be a snooze fest
but I really
since every game is just beautiful so
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your evening the
end the day